[Música]
el presidente de Brasil se enfrenta este
domingo a la izquierda está Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva en el primer debate antes
de la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales del próximo 30 de octubre
unas polémicas declaraciones afectan al
actual mandatario en un fin de semana
clave tenemos informe desde Río de
Janeiro
comenzó el congreso del partido
comunista chino es la cita en la que se
espera que el presidente
asuma a su tercer periodo al frente del
gigante asiático la política y la
defensa de Taiwán fueron las prioridades
de su discurso en la jornada inaugural
decenas de miles de personas marcharon
este domingo en París en rechazo al alto
costo de vida y la inacción climática la
movilización la organiza la alianza
opositora de izquierda nupes su líder
Jean look melanchoe habla del comienzo
de un nuevo frente popular
tiempo de actualizar las noticias aquí
en la pantalla de France 24 Gracias por
estar con nosotros
ese domingo en eso Pablo se ven las
caras el presidente de Brasil ya
revolucionaron
el próximo 30 de octubre en la segunda
vuelta de los comicios presidenciales
unas polémicas declaraciones de bolso
dardo están agitando la campaña este fin
de semana con la previa de este debate
está desde Río de Janeiro nuestra
corresponsal valeresa quien previamente
nos envió el siguiente informe
el debate va a acontecer hoy en el medio
de una gran polémica desde ayer en las
redes sociales el presidente Yair
bolsonares haciendo acusado de pedofilia
por unas declaraciones que él hizo en
una entrevista en un podcast famoso
sobre fútbol personal o recordó un
episodio del año pasado cuando andaba en
moto por Brasilia y vio un grupo de
chicas de unos 14 15 años de Venezuela
el presidente dijo que eran muy bonita y
usa una frase infeliz pintó un clima me
interesé Solo que esta frase en
portugués tiene un Matiz sexual
conclusión de la historia y la
entrevista bolsonaro cuenta que entró en
la casa se encontró con chicas jóvenes
maquilladas y arregladas y el presidente
llega la conclusión de que se estaban
prostituyendo y aprovecho el episodio
para criticar el gobierno de maduro en
Venezuela sin embargo hoy una de las
chicas
ha declarado en la prensa nacional que
no se trataba de prostitución Y sí de un
curso gratuito y solidario para
refugiadas venezolanas era un curso de
estética y por eso las chicas estaban
pintadas desde anoche en las redes
sociales haciendo acusado por la
oposición y por la sociedad civil o bien
de ser pedófilo o bien de haberse
omitido ante una hipotética
red de prostitución de menores su
principal rival el ex presidente Lula
está usando Este vídeo También para
atacarles con lo cual todo apunta a que
hoy el debate puede estar muy caliente
justamente en frases 24 tendremos
cobertura especial de este encuentro
entre los candidatos al palacio de plan
alto los invitamos a conectarse con
nosotros A partir de las 18 horas hora
de Bogotá quito y Lima en un programa
presentado por nuestro compañero Andrés
Meza Muñoz
cinco días después de que el gobierno de
Estados Unidos comenzará a deportar a
México a los inmigrantes venezolanos que
lleguen a la Unión Americana por tierra
de manera irregular estas caravanas
continúan emprendiendo su camino hacia
suelo estadounidense este domingo
decenas de personas comenzaron su
travesía por el tapón del Darién una
peligrosa selva en la frontera entre
Colombia y Panamá la mayoría de estas
personas son de Venezuela y algunos de
ellos realizan Esterio que incluso con
niños Estados Unidos promete que
permitirá el ingreso de hasta 24.000
ciudadanos de Venezuela que arriban por
vía aérea pero los migrantes consideran
que no es suficiente
malos gobiernos de maduro y su entorno
porque Venezuela es un país bello de
oportunidades donde sea tiene todos los
minerales posibles y
las malas administración tenemos
nosotros nos lleva nos lleva a este
destino este viaje por el futuro de mis
hijos y por la familia también entonces
gracias a Dios nos dando a buenas
noticias pero queremos llegar en el
nombre de Dios a ver lo primordial es
que Dios nos dé salud No de fuerza y
llega a Panamá lo adelante vamos sin
titulares el presidente de China
inauguró este domingo de la edición
número 20 del congreso del partido
comunista del país el mandatario que
podría ser reelecto para un tercer
periodo al frente de esa potencia
pronunció un discurso en el que defendió
su política de cero covid alertó sobre
la situación de Taiwán y eligió la
gobernabilidad conseguida en Hong Kong
también pidió acelerar la construcción
de un ejército de clase mundial Manuel
acano con los detalles
un estruendoso aplauso resonó en el
salón del pueblo en Beijing la ovación
recibió el presidente chino chiquitín
quien pronunció un discurso de una hora
y media en la inauguración de la edición
número 20 del Congreso comunista del
país el mandatario resaltó algunos de
los puntos de su gestión y defendió
otros de los más criticados como la
política de cero covid que tuvo
detractores incluso dentro del partido
comunista
en particular ante la repentina pandemia
de Kobe 19 nos adherimos a los
principios de las personas primero la
vida primero y también nos adherimos
firmemente a la política dinámica de
cero covid para llevar a cabo la lucha
contra la pandemia
ante 2.300 representantes de todo el
país chilling ping puso en el centro de
la locución a Taiwán y aseguró que
aunque china está a favor de la
reunificación pacífica el presidente
reitero que jamás renuncia al uso de la
fuerza de ser necesaria
ante las actividades sensacionistas de
las fuerzas independentistas de Taiwán y
las graves provocaciones de las fuerzas
externas que se inmiscuyan en los
asuntos de Taiwán
lanzado decididamente una gran lucha
contra la secesión y la injerencia
demostrando nuestra firme determinación
Y capacidad para salvaguardar la
soberanía nacional y la integridad
territorial y oponernos a la
independencia de Taiwán
otro punto álgido en la agenda Hong Kong
resaltó lo que denominó una transición
del caos a la gobernabilidad en 2020 el
gobierno había implementado una ley de
seguridad nacional Para calmar los
ánimos en el territorio autónomo que fue
fuertemente criticada por los países
occidentales por atentar contra las
libertades el congreso se prolongará
hasta el 22 de octubre y se espera que
sí sea reelecto para un tercer mandato
algo inédito entre sus predecesores y
pensaría su poder en el gigante asiático
el medio oriente este domingo el
presidente iraní de brahim Racing cargó
contra somólogo de Estados Unidos
joeyden dos días después de que este
último pidiera al gobierno de la
República islámica acabar con la
violencia contra sus ciudadanos esto en
medio de cuatro semanas de marchas en
rechazó la situación de Derechos Humanos
en Irán
creemos que Estados Unidos está detrás
de la destrucción el terror o los
disturbios y el caos en la región y en
el mundo eso Afirma nuestra creencia y
la creencia del mundo que los
estadounidenses están enojados y
molestos con cada Innovación felicidad o
bien que le sucede a Irán
cambiamos de tema este domingo el
edificio de la Administración prorrusa
en la ciudad de dones que fue alcanzado
por bombardeos de las fuerzas ucranianas
en un momento en el que la
contraofensiva de kiev continua
acumulando éxitos las autoridades
locales afirmaron que no hay Muertos
pero civiles resultaron heridos miembros
del comité de investigación ruso ya
abordan una pesquisa para obtener
mayores detalles en tanto que Ucrania no
ha reaccionado al caso el informe es de
Ramiro cueva Barberena
la contraofensiva ucraniana continúa su
avance sobre objetivos clave este
domingo el edificio administrativo que
las autoridades prorrusas tienen en la
ciudad de dañes fue severamente dañado
en un bombardeo la entrada principal fue
convertida en escombros y vehículos
cercanos resultaron destruidos las
autoridades separatistas notificaron
heridos pero no lamentan fallecidos
fue un golpe directo el edificio está
seriamente dañado es un milagro que
nadie haya muerto
desde que no reclamaron aún la autoría
de los hechos para Rusia ahora es el
momento de Elevar una investigación y
apunta a un ataque con misiles y Mars
entregados por Washington
todos los fragmentos serán enviados para
su examen luego se establecerá Qué tipo
de proyectil era se ha abierto un caso
penal las autoridades investigativas
están estudiando este incidente
ha estado controlada por fuerzas
prorusas de 2014 y junto a gerson lugans
y saporiya ha sido ilegalmente
anexionada recientemente tras unos
controvertidos referendos impulsados por
Moscú este ataque sucede en momentos en
los que la guerra aparece haber entrado
en una nueva fase de violencia Ucrania
avanza y recupera kilómetros cuadrados
de territorio en regiones ocupadas y
Rusia lanzó el mayor ataque con misiles
sobre diferentes ciudades ucranianas
desde el inicio de la invasión tras
acusar a Ucrania de un ataque terrorista
contra el puente de crimea nos vamos a
Francia porque este domingo París vivió
una jornada de manifestaciones para
exigir medidas que ayuden a fallar el
incremento del costo de vida así como
una mayor acción del gobierno de la
primera ministra Elizabeth bong y del
presidente Emmanuel macron frente al
cambio climático en las protestas
participaron 30.000 personas según las
autoridades pero los organizadores
afirman que eran 140.000 para este
martes Se esperan más marchas de
sindicatos que llaman a una huelga
general
cargado no se amplía
miles de personas salieron a las calles
de París en una jornada de protestas por
el aumento del coste de vida y lo que
los manifestantes consideran como una
inacción climática por parte del
gobierno la izquierda es la gran
protagonista de la jornada especialmente
líder de nupes melanchoe quien intentó
capitalizar el descontento social que
reina en Francia gran éxito de la marcha
16 de octubre 140.000 personas se
movilizaron contra una vida costosa la
inacción climática y la reforma de las
pensiones
los manifestantes exigen el cumplimiento
de 5 puntos principales
jubilación a los 60 años actualmente en
Francia la edad para pensionarse es de
62 años y Emanuel maccom propone que la
edad necesaria sea de 64 o 65 años un
subsidio de autonomía de 1100 euros para
los jóvenes de 16 a 25 años cuyas
familias tengan ingresos por debajo de
los 2000 euros esto con el objetivo
facilitar su inserción en el mundo
laboral impuestos a los beneficios
extraordinarios de las grandes
corporaciones e impulsar políticas
ambientales basadas en la utilización de
energías renovables y el modelo de
bifurcación ecológica llegó hace parte
del movimiento chalecos amarillos
critica el rol de las empresas en la
crisis que vive el país es fácil para
una empresa decir que sus trabajadores
ganan aproximadamente 9.000 euros cuando
el promedio se basa en el salario de los
ejecutivos y el director general pero el
sueldo de la mayoría de la gente se
reduce a 1.500 euros de los cuales 500
son para pagar la gasolina las protestas
se dan en medio de la huelga de los dos
principales sindicatos de la importante
empresa de refinería Total energys que
exige Un aumento de su salario
el Sindicato de trabajadores cgt expresó
que no comparte la totalidad de las
exigencias hechas hoy en las calles y
tendrá su propia movilización el próximo
18 de octubre día en el que se espera
que haya una huelga general de
sindicatos
este domingo se conmemora el Día Mundial
de la Alimentación la fecha llega en un
momento en el que según el programa
mundial de alimentos el planeta se aleja
de sus objetivos de acabar con el hambre
para 2030 alerta también de las
múltiples causas que están proliferando
este flagelo una de ellas es el cambio
climático generando las sequías cada vez
mayores que ponen en jaque a varias
poblaciones a nivel internacional siendo
el este de África una de las regiones
más afectadas
cadáveres de animales sobre tierra
totalmente seca de la tanga sequía que
atraviesa el condado equilify en Kenia
allí cultivar se ha vuelto un imposible
con la última vez que cultivamos y
obtuvimos productos fue hace cinco años
por eso Estamos cortando árboles para
hacer carbón para alimentarnos
la sequía no es nueva en Kenia según la
Cruz Roja el país está experimentando un
tercer año sin lluvias y se estima que
3,1 millones de personas están
amenazadas por una grave escasez de
alimentos
hemos dependido mucho de la agricultura
ahora hace tanto tiempo que no llueve
eso se ha convertido en un gran desafío
y ahora no tenemos alimentos en resumen
estamos obteniendo alimentos Pero no es
lo que se necesitan no es una dieta
balanceada
la situación es especialmente
preocupante para los niños en este
centro asistencial día a día llegan en
estado de desnutrición
los informes e incluso la situación está
empeorando en el sentido en que
analizamos las cifras en términos de
niños desnutridos que recibimos en
nuestras instalaciones y esto podría
deberse a la inseguridad alimentaria
ocasionada por la situación de sequía
hay un repunte en las cifras en toda la
región del este de África 4,2 millones
de personas se enfrentan a una grave
inseguridad alimentaria
según la red humanitaria de tierras
áridas y semiáridas una situación que
podría empeorar en el marco del Día
Mundial de la Alimentación de 2022 la
FAO alertó que el mundo se está alejando
de sus esfuerzos por eliminar el hambre
según cifras de la ONU el número de
personas que padecen hambre en el mundo
aumentó hasta alcanzar los 828 millones
de personas en 2021 unos 46 millones más
que en 2020 y se prevé que casi 670
millones de personas el 8% de la
población mundial seguirán pasando
hambre en 2030
Así concluimos esta emisión informativa
nuestra pantalla pero ustedes quédense
en nuestra señal la información también
continúa en France 24.com
[Música]